buonasera tutto bene siamo tornati
ragazzi su hunger games chiamiamo tutti
gli stretti della volta scorsa che non
sto a ripresentare come l'altra volta
perché in editing ci metto quattro ore a
far vedere tutti i team singolarmente io
c'ho la pigrizia anche nell'anima quindi
sticazzi quelli dell'altra volta più o
meno tranne il fatto che salvatore sta
con fox faceless che sarà l'ultima volta
che ho giocato a questa roba su due
partite che ho fatto ha vinto due volte
pietro questa volta pietro per sicurezza
l'ho tolto partenza ragazzi mentre gli
omaggi status i podi suona il corno che
aprì ponte scappa dalla cornucopia si
parte così della gomes scappai occupo
dei mantella se scappa fedez rompe il
naso di jason per un cesto di pane con
tutto rispetto che ho per x files non so
come il ragazzo faccia a rompere il naso
di jason com'è possibile nel vinto
scorso adesso ti faceva il culo punto vi
facciamo il culo tutti ma soggetto con
quanto fa schifo bescapè sabrina e
scappa sasha scappare nasca proprio
prima giulia penna uccide martin garics
con la propria arma è ma io con limone
lì ho passato un sacco di dei di poteri
a giulia seno kuga tempi e scappa da
cornucopia j ax rimanere
tutti che scappano mai perfetto non sono
morto il primo turno dobbiamo
festeggiare ragazze gli archi op op
antialias raccoglie i frutti da un
albero tutore sabri gamer tracciano e
uccidono giulia penna ma povera mi
chiama già fatto un achille già morta
daniela esplorare na albano mette in
dubbio la sua sanità
[Musica]
stefano chiede a vita di ucciderlo
rifiuta tenendo stefano vivo sasha
uccide più di payment sta riposando ma
non si va dai meno un incontro serio
sasha fa vige dice è un esclusivo da uno
sforzo sconosciuto venduto raccomandato
ma che devo fare i place mentali
esplosive condurrà della dinamite
economica marzi attacca gabry ponte ma
salvatore cinquegrana lo protegge
uccidendo marzia j ax strangola jason
credibile o ma che jason rammollito sei
gli ato copan della sofferta uno zaino
non rendendosi conto che vuoto si cosa
facciamo il culo a tutti i cristiani
gardens con il mio con la mia cha da
guerra o con il mio adattatore per
l'accorrente compratelo zaini fa vigente
questo non è un placement sono morti
martin garics giulia penna vegas di pai
marsi e jason procede la notte uno siamo
arrivati alla notte ragazze vita piagge
per dormire
non credo funzioni credo che piangere
prima di dormire concilia il sonno
però i lutti semplici imposta marco
marino in fiamme con una moto marco mio
cosa ne pensi che ti ha dato fuoco a
macomer i non ha mandato wetransfer ha
bruciato barbecue grazie lorenzo ma che
bravo no grazie perché no è perché si
andava grazie grazie grazie
poiché però voglio scusa ma dai ragazzi
procedere non sono ancora molto anzi ho
fatto una kill incredibile che non credo
di essere io in questo momento punto e
albano lavorano insieme ma cosa questo è
diventato pazzo canta da solo tutto
scappa daniel plants hellas mette in
dubbio la sua sanità e con quei capelli
anche io effettivamente le mettere in
dubbio sasha traccia e uccide salvatore
ma no un'amicizia rovinata e di mezzi
che si fanno la guerra tra di loro
potrebbe essere un buon titolo peak
beriche morto morto salvatore poverino
marco
non poco mi dispiace che fu gabry ponte
perfetto sembrano e che mi disse si
incontrano ha deciso di fermarsi per la
notte che scoop incredibile marina so
cazzi tua moto fa vj perde la vista lì
dove si trova
capito ma non sono morto quindi va bene
j ax pensa di vincere
pensa di vincere quello che vinciamo
senza lottare albano tenta di salire su
un albero ma cade su sasha uccidendo
entrambi scuse prezzo appena letto
sapri viene svegliato da incubi turbo
race del tour turbo lo ripetiamo turbo
bravi che riceve cibo fresco dallo
spazio sconosciuto compreso al mini
beretta spariscono in fretta come la
sanitaria in mano tributi caduti ok al
bano e sasha poveretti sono ammazzati da
soli altro che missile predator che
colpisce la gente mica albano
lanciamogli al bando sulle persone
selena gomez fox fei scopo panthers
daniel pantella se fa vj stracciano e
uccidono tutor c'è un 12 per ammazzare
tutto quanto forte ma neanche fosse
jason secondo me tudor e jason si sono
scambiati l'identità è una mia ipotesi
d'aria il punt hellas non è in grado di
convincere ariana grande a non ucciderla
ucciderla perché danno della donna a
daniel un giro in funzionato oppure tu
ha già ok se mi si ricorda che pensa
attacca parigi e cala ma riesce a
scappare attenzione sono creativo step
ricerca rilanciare di lanciare pesci con
un tridente semmai pescare madonna che
produzione di merda morto daniel morto
tudor ucciso da 20 persone insieme
valeva vj mette in dubbio la sua sanità
per quello lo faccio sempre kennis
avvelenata bevanda di p.ta bene e muore
ma come mi chiama tutto l'amore che c'è
tra vita e katniss dov'è andato a finire
con eccesso si fa sta cosa solo per la
freddo maledizione che gli si mette
fuori un esplosivo uccidendo for space
si sono ammazzati quelli del film
originale attenzione poi vien decide di
non andare alla festa mica il solito
sociale già perché permette fuori un
esplosivo ci negò felek serena gomez non
c'è un coltello nella testa di stefano
bus e tram fascia fortissimo ariana
grande scopre applicato rimasti
pochissimi laga ariana grande scoprono
grotta sapere scopro fiume famiglia
intende alle ferite di katniss quindi
sono stato anche mangiare
lei ha tentato di uccidermi maiolo e la
sto curando perché io ci credo nella
patata bianca poppante la si scopre una
grotta senato ne scoprono fiume davanti
la situazione amica di morti pita fox
sei specie se stefano vedi lo stato di
tutti siamo incredibile sono primo con
due kill non sono primo la prima sabrina
jacopo dei fan the last e riceve il cibo
fresco da uno sponsor fa vj ariana
grande si scontrano decidono di fermarsi
per la notte fa sempre bene credere
nella patata perché alla fine porta
risultati province che chiede visto si
nutrono per il caldo non sono ancora
morto selena gomez cade in una forza e
muore sembri generali a como con the
last raccontano storie tra i loro marina
grande esce dall'esaurimento procedere è
morta selena gomez pensione me ne frega
niente stato trovato lariana grande come
[ __ ] va bene lo stesso s'apre gamer
pugni fa vj nella parte posteriore con
un tridente fame maledetta sapri ero
arrivato alla fine mi chiamo ammazzato
sapri chiedere con un tridente porca eva
avrei tirato fuori un [ __ ] tridente
alla grande e muore dalla 7 sapri spinge
gli ato poppante l'asta una scogliera
durante una lotta di coltelli tempi di
sucate da una fossa e cuore la
vincitrice degli hunger games sa
previene venne anche ucciso a [ __ ]
non te lo meritavi ci posso credere
abbia vinto sapri prima pietro coi sabri
dei ragazzi spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto che compiuto qui anche oggi con
gli hunger games tanti colpi di scena il
suo gioco mi piace sempre tanto perché
succedono cagate di continuo non vi
spero mi sia piaciuto ragazzi cosa
mi piace anche le isole sono introdotti
nel tiziana senza che si scateni
l'impianto seguito le ragazze
[Musica]